does that answer that for you it does
and yet
it brings up what you had talked about
yesterday when i sat in on part of your
class about um
a lot of dark characters have this karma
deflector oh
and then it finally all comes down yeah
can you talk about that that's okay
so it's said in a lot of the magical
mystical
metaphysical lore that those who work on
the dark side
you know the dark magicians as opposed
to the white magicians and think again
lord of the rings
you know gandalf versus sarmat right
so you think well okay what about karma
you do all these horrible things you
wipe out people you kill whole planets
and worlds
well where's the karma there where's the
retribution because
we want life to be in balance seldom is
it but that's what we like
so it's said that the dark magicians are
able to
deflect their karma it's like they have
a deflector shield around them
and they are protected from the bounce
back of what they do
what they can also have is a group of
devotees
apostles followers fans who take the hit
for them and usually the people don't
know that that's what they're doing
but you start working for a dark
magician guess what your life starts
falling apart
may not be just what you're doing you're
getting some of his deflected karma
or you know she is directly pointing
that shield to
you so it goes off of her and bounces
down to the other people
but ultimately there comes a time
in the life of a dark magician in their
career through the dark side
that it just doesn't work anymore and
then
all that they have been holding back
whether it's aging
you know someone who's had the youth
spell whether
it's uh rotting from the inside out
whether it's being
slain by the tools that you used to slay
other people
it eventually comes back but that karma
deflector is a
really good story tool
you